it didn't seem that outlandish to me
gaion guy kissing that the kissing thing
is not even remotely the most intimate
things that we do in the mouth tongue
grabby grabby tongue for some reason
very weird and a farting corpse no doubt
Daniel Radcliffe and Paul Danos Swiss
Army man is not your average movie I
think when you yeah we were all together
job yeah yeah it's the duo's first film
together but Daniel had acted alongside
Paul's girlfriend Zoe Kazan while Paul
once worked with Daniel's girlfriend
Aaron dark is one of the witnesses of
the film industry so we had to ask did
they have better chemistry with each
other or each other's girlfriends
ah that's impossible question to answer
I think I think we've all done very well
in all various configurations of this
love triangle in the movie out July 1st
Daniel plays the farting corpse who gets
dragged around by Paul Daniel I mean
dude was getting dragged around and just
never complained once Daniel has a
simple message for those unwilling to
give it a chance your loss
but thinks his Harry Potter fans will
dig it generally speaking Potter fans
are very curious and open and so most of
them I think will enjoy this movie